and he returns to TV anytime soon
episode 14 of season 11 for starters
RuPaul's Drag Race Season ten champ
aquaria stepping out for the season 11
finale cut it into the finale
who are you rooting for oh my goodness
I'm so ready for myself I think I still
have a chance to turn in and snatch the
crown again but no um I think everyone's
really shown a lot of fun characters
this season and some really different
takes on what we've seen so far I'm just
going to see how this whole format goes
down how everything works and if
anyone's game right now I want to do
some rapid fire about the season
okeydoke it's quick as possible what was
the worst fashion moment of season 11 oh
my goodness the shoes from everybody
period oh my god never worn heels like
this hi no what was the quote of the
season for you I'm always team up
Allen's you earn everything you earn and
what was the lip-synch moment of the
season for you um I feel like it's yet
to come I'll have to see you tonight
we are playing a game tonight where all
the queens are leaving questions for
each other
the last question left was if you have
to pick one girl to go home first week
from drag with which going would it be
Michelle there a lack of creativity
years and what's the question you want
to leave Ramon a soap what up question
mark talk about a $2,000 [ __ ] all right
I know your world just keeps getting
bigger crazier Wilder what do the next
few months look like aquaria
how am I gonna so I just got I'm just
finishing up now too
European tour with work the world which
was really exciting and I recently just
had my Mac paper glam campaign come out
but I also have some really fun other
makeup collaborations in the very very
near future coming up her dry con so
keep an eye out for that and then I'll
be back in the fall traveling all over
North America with the work the world
tour as well
[Music]